this video is sponsored by brilliant
start learning for free with a link in
the description
and the first 200 get 20 off the annual
premium subscription
ming was born april 1982 in china's
fujian province
his mother a nurse and father the owner
of an electronics factory
were unusual and that they gave their
son the freedom to explore his interests
namely technology this little did they
know
would put zheng on the path to become
china's mark zuckerberg
in 2001 he left to study engineering
near beijing
which he chose for the quote pretty
girls and winter snow
while zuckerberg two years younger and 6
000 miles away
entered harvard met his wife and started
facebook
jang fixed computers met his wife and
built
his startup after several failed
ventures
in 2012 he founded a new company called
bite dance from his small beijing
apartment
and although his path was rockier than
zuckerberg's
it was no less abrupt or explosive
by the end of its first year facebook
had registered 1 million users
by dance's first breakthrough a chinese
video sharing app
had 100 million then having conquered
the chinese market
the company turned global buying its
competitor
and the spiritual successor to vine
called musically
in 2017 later rebranded as tick tock
outside of china
the app now ubiquitous among young
people everywhere
makes it almost too easy to shoot edit
and share videos
usually in the form of dancing comedy
skits and stream of consciousness
monologues the real genius of tiktok
however
and what sets it apart from snapchat
instagram
and facebook is the part you don't see
the much alluded to guarded like a state
secret
algorithm rather than by following
friends
tick tock learns on its own exactly what
you like
as you mindlessly scroll through its
endless feed of videos
you don't need to follow like or search
for it to understand your preferences
and the more you scroll the better it
gets at reading your mind
this is also what makes it so addicting
unlike twitter or instagram where you
can stay up to date on your timeline
ticktalk will keep you entertained for
however many hours you allow it
knowing this it's two billion downloads
and it's only
four years of existence and bite dance's
position as the most valuable private
company
in the world are impressive but not
altogether
surprising equally so jang's personal
wealth of around 16 billion dollars
making him the 10th richest person in
china and 61st
in the world today at 38 years old
he's still described as the nerdy
awkward uncharismatic but
undeniably resourceful mirror image of
zuckerberg
in his rare public appearances he often
comes across
as robotic and overly rational there is
however
one obvious major difference between
these two internet titans
jang built his company in china while
facebook had to first allow a foreign
government to interfere in a
presidential election
before congress would even begin
considering regulation
tick tock faced legal constraints from
the very beginning
what's remarkable about its success is
that it's neither a clone of a
foreign-made app
nor like huawei aided financially by the
chinese government
just as impressive it resisted
acquisition by alibaba
tencent or any other deep-pocketed tech
giant
by not doing so tick-tock arguably
became
china's first true consumer technology
export success story
and all on its own overcoming its
limitations
despite being based in china not because
of it
prevailing in this challenging
environment affords jang even greater
praise
but also subjects his empire to a
potential collapse
just as instantaneous as it was built
it took only a few short years for tick
tock to surpass
in downloads some of the biggest
companies in the world
but it may take only a few emphatic pen
strokes
for all that progress to be lost
on june 29th 2020 the second most
populous country in the world
and by far tick tock's biggest market
the republic of india
banned it along with 60 other chinese
mobile apps
accused of stealing and sending user
data outside of the country
ironically this came as a surprise to a
nation whose great firewall has
methodically banned
censored and regulated foreign media for
decades
with this one swift move millions of
viewers and creators
some of whom depended on the app for a
significant portion of their living
were simply out of luck just as
significant
was the potential domino effect this
decision could have
tick tock's largest source of downloads
this year in order
are india brazil and the us the latter
of which
is a prime contender for the next domino
to fall
this in fact undersells the significance
of the u.s market
when divided by platform it's revealed
as a major source of iphone users
who spend on average two and a half
times more on
apps what this means is that while
americans account for only ten percent
of tick tock's overall user base
they make up an incredible 56 percent of
its revenue
a ban by the us would not simply limit
its growth
but require a fundamental restructuring
of its business
to say nothing of the potential for
other countries to follow its lead
what then is the likelihood of such a
ban
and would it be justified
even before any real arguments are made
fear of tick-tock
may to some seem reasonable if only
because
such fear is so widespread and came
about
so suddenly the list of skeptics even
prior to india's ban
is long after a regional office was
established in sydney
australian authorities began
investigating the app on suspicion of
foreign interference
and violations of data privacy both the
u.s
democratic and republican national
committees have asked staffers not to
install the app
or to buy a second phone when using it
for campaign work
as have the us department of state
homeland security and military
even private companies have followed
suit including the bank wells fargo
and amazon although the latter retracted
its statement shortly afterward
tensions reached a new high when the
trump administration strongly alluded to
a ban
at the same time as the president's
re-election campaign bought facebook ads
saying quote tick-tock is spying on you
and have been
quote caught red-handed should this
decision be made
several levers are at its disposal first
the committee on foreign investment
whose job is to monitor national
security concerns
could force bite dance to sell off its
american operations to an approved buyer
alternatively the trump administration
could invoke the international emergency
economic powers act
or place tick-tock on the entity list
which would force its removal from the
app stores
as in the case of huawei's ban almost
exactly one year ago
skeptics are quick to point out the
preferential treatment it would give to
american competitors
as if on cue instagram is expected to
launch
its tick tock competitor called reels in
the u.s
this august snapchat byte likey
and youtube have also tried replicating
the concept
even netflix listed the app as a
competitor in its latest letter to
shareholders
a sign of just how time consuming it's
become
also like huawei the claims made against
it are sometimes
vague hard to disprove and yet also
extremely consequential
several independent observers allege the
app censors content in accordance with
mainland chinese guidelines
for example in the absence of videos
covering the pro-democracy protests in
hong kong
the company has publicly admitted to
limiting the reach of disabled queer and
overweight creators
which it claims was for their own
protection against bullying
before changing policies a bug it says
was responsible for showing no views on
videos related to black lives matter
on one hand the nebulousness of the
algorithm allows anyone to claim
censorship without strong supporting
evidence
on the other this provides cover for
tick-tock in that it can always remind
them that the algorithm is based on
their preferences
and that any perceived manipulation is
only a reflection of their behavior
more concretely the company has paid
five million
and one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars respectively to u.s
and korean authorities for collecting
the personal information of children
without parental consent
however unlike huawei the controversy
surrounds not critical communications
infrastructure but a lip-syncing dancing
app for teens
a tick-tock band raises far more
eyebrows because the idea of such an app
presenting a threat to national security
is a much less intuitive argument this
critics would say is precisely what
makes it such an effective tool
nobody suspects it a preview of what it
could become
if left unregulated is the version of
the app in china
which is home to a much older audience
is used by police to spread information
and has advanced face recognition such
was the backdrop of skepticism
against which more recent discoveries
were made
when the beta of the next version of ios
was released this summer
a new privacy feature was included which
alerts users when an app
copies their clipboard it didn't take
long before videos like this
one emerged showing tick-tock almost
constantly reading whatever is copied
more careful digging also found the app
recording a user's screen size
as well as other information about their
device
these findings are a trap
well-intentioned as they may be
they only distract from other far more
serious concerns
experts agree that tick-tock's data
collection practices
are not only not rare but actually quite
restrained when compared with other
ad-based services like facebook
reddit and linkedin for instance were
also caught reading the clipboard
which they say is used to prevent spam
bite dance has explicitly repeated that
it does not
employ moderators in china and that u.s
data
is stored in the u.s with backups in
singapore
by nearly focusing on the technical
details the issue
is reframed as one of privacy which
could just as easily be applied to any
application
including and especially those based in
america
it's no coincidence rather that those
most familiar with chinese politics
are also the app's most vocal critics
tiktok is not just another social
network
because china is not just another
country
this is also not to say that the company
doesn't mean what it says
one of the most unfortunate byproducts
of its place of birth is that tick-tock
may be dangerous
through no fault of its own china's 2017
national intelligence law
compels all companies with information
stored within its borders
to hand over data at its request without
the constraints of courts or warrants
if this sounds only theoretical bite
dance's first app was shut down in 2018
by the national radio and television
administration
after which jang apologized for his poor
adherence to socialist core values
in practice this control extends much
further than its borders
a company need not be based or even
physically present
at all in china for it to be beholden
financially
it does not matter that bite dance is
incorporated in the cayman islands
or that zoom is headquartered in
california or that the nba
is in every sense of the word american
for their checks are signed elsewhere
none of this is particularly new
china has effectively operated a
separate internet for years
which foreign companies have gained
access to by self-censoring
what has changed is that until recently
this has been relatively easy to deny or
ignore
now at a time of record bipartisanship
in favor of a tougher response to china
it is no longer possible to feign
ignorance
whereas before appeasing china was the
common sense profit maximizing business
tactic
to gain access to its 1.4 billion users
with minimal casualties
elsewhere now there's a trade-off
and as companies are forced to confront
this reality they will
inevitably decide on one of three
general approaches
the first group will rip off the
band-aid as quickly as possible
they'll cut their losses by leaving the
chinese market entirely
and spending massively on pr against
their competitors who don't
while facing backlash from investors a
second group will do
just the opposite these mostly
chinese-based companies will see
international expansion as more
liability than it's worth
and leave the non-chinese market notably
this does not constrain them to the
mainland but would likely include
developing markets which can't afford to
be scrupulous when offered investment
finally some especially international
companies will see either option as too
high a cost to bear
and make the highest reward yet highest
risk
gamble to juggle both these firms will
split in two
and each division will try its hardest
to distance itself from the other
if they fail pressure will grow until
enough value is lost that a deal will be
made
and one or both divisions will be sold
to a disinterested investor
tick-tock is a prime example of the
third strategy
in the last several months alone it's
hired a new american ex-disney ceo
announced its plans to add another 10
000 u.s jobs in the next three years
doubled its lobbying budget and after
the national security law was
promulgated in hong kong
left the special administrative region
entirely
however with an election less than 100
days away
it seems unlikely these moves will be
nearly drastic enough
even a majority sale to a us investor
may not assuage fears during a time of
intense scrutiny towards china
and a presidency at stake such is the
predicament
it's impossible to divorce any action
from these political circumstances
and yet that doesn't automatically
disqualify arguments in favor of a ban
it is rare but not the least bit
contradictory to admit that
a it is politically popular to attack
companies for their ties to the prc
and would still be whether or not such
fears were founded
and b tick tock poses a very real
potential threat to the interests of the
us
and other countries simply because of
its ties to china
and c there is a deeply troubling
growing tendency to associate anything
broadly labeled chinese as
untrustworthy to ban tiktok would create
a kind of great american firewall
against the will of american users and
yet not doing so would subject the
country to greater risk
there is however one neutral path
forward
to pass regulation governing where data
can be stored
requiring disclosure of the algorithm
local ownership
and creating mechanisms for auditing and
enforcement
doing so although seen as less
politically strong
would subject all companies foreign and
otherwise
to the same fair standards tick-tock
would remain
giving american companies greater
competition and incentive to innovate
companies like facebook would be forced
to respect their users privacy
and all without provoking backlash for
targeting a specific group of people
this
is a long-term solution for a long-term
problem
because although tiktok was one of the
first chinese apps to go
global it certainly won't be the last
there will be another huawei another
zoom
and another tick tock and how the world
responds
now will set the tone of what's to come
tik tok is the product of one man's
intense interest and technology
and curiosity to learn more its rise
proves that the next big idea
won't necessarily come from facebook
google or apple
it could come from you if you're
watching this video
you're clearly interested in tech and
motivated to learn on your own
and you can take the next step on your
entrepreneurial journey with the
programming cryptocurrency and machine
learning courses
on brilliant at a time when school is
closed and classes are going online
now is the time to take charge of your
own education and brilliant is just the
place to do so
with its beautifully made interactive
step-by-step lessons
available on both its mobile app and
website
its engaging explanations and challenges
are what textbooks
should be when you're ready to start
hands-on learning
and get 20 off the annual premium
subscription for the first 200 people
join brilliant for free with the link in
the description